jean paul gaultier bonsoir lors gauthier
sa vie son oeuvre du public et mémoire
ça y est sous forme de roman photo
ça s'appelle à nous de la mode et ça
s'est passé comment c'est quoi la génèse
de cette affaire
bah ce qui s'est passé c'est que ben on
m'avait déjà proposé plusieurs fois de
faire un livre d'écrire un livre
et puis en fin de compte je me sens pas
du tout capable d'écrire et vichy même
pas capable d'écrire une carte postale
là j'ai du mal j'ai beaucoup de mal j'ai
dit et tout ça prend trop de temps alors
du coup je ne fait pas bon elle imite
les croix c'est ce que je peux faire
comme je crois on a eu un coup de fil
après je crois française vernis lisant
justement qu'elle voulait faire un livre
ou que j'écrive un livre moi je dis
c'est impossible alors il y avait la
ressource bien sûr du du [ __ ] ouais que
je n'apprécie pas tellement parce que en
fin de compte je pensais c'est un peu
mentir quoi alors donc bombe à la sauce
chaude alors j'ai réfléchi je me suis
dit non c'est pas possible je vais pas
envie non plus un livre avec oui parce
que pour moi la mode c'est quoi ce que
c'était parler de la mode évidemment
d'amos et les images avant tout je suis
un enfant des images j'aime la télé
j'aime le cinéma je ne lis pas alors que
les gens en lisant un livre s'ennuie
comme moi je pourrais m'ennuyer en
lisant un j'avais pas tellement envie
donc je vais montrer des images heures
je me suis dit le roman-photo toi c'est
très bien car scénarios patrick rambaud
oui conseillère monique pivot et
spécialiste des éditions mondiales qui
fait tousser journal à la perfection
1 ça vaut pas cher en plus c'est rigolo
95 points
alors il ya aujourd'hui sans couleurs
j'ai discuté avec jean teulé de copains
de bernard rapp et puis après tout les
flash back en noir et blanc alors il ya
la vocation loi maquille et on nous tue
mais qui est vraiment on nous ressasse
est vrai un j'ai encore l'ours qui est
là et tout c'est un petit monstre parce
que je le faisais soubie subir un petit
peu tout ce qui se passait à l'époque
c'était l'époque où il y avait une
opération à coeur ouvert professeur
barnard gelot prm alors pas à coeur
ouvert un petit peu là au milieu là et
puis avec des épingles je refusais y
avait le mariage de favols fabiola et de
du roi baudouin paraissent marienne
voilà alors il ya des faux l'été
fabiola il ya d'autres fois ils
étendaient de l'humeur alors on va être
à mes cheveux bleus redécoller et puis
alors ton père dont il n'a pas le beau
rôle à ben non alors mais là je mettais
mes parents il faut jamais quand même
été très du champ avant cela les
dentellières c'est quand même ben oui
avec des traits plus dur et l'évaluer
macho il ya un truc très rigolo ça me
fait penser à la pub de guy degrenne
cessé à un moment tu es en classe et
puis on échappe en train de dessiner des
p&t infâme avec des corses et des trucs
c'est exact je ne ferai jamais rien donc
monsieur guy degrenne
c'est un petit peu ça ouais je crois que
il ya pas mal de guy degrenne non dans
plein de domaines en fin de compte et ça
c'est à dire que je dessinais comme moi
je regardais tout le temps la télé ma
grand mère quand même que génial me
laissait voir tout la télévision à la
maison qu'il avait le rectangle blanc j
le toutim dam dom
dim dam dom bon ça c'est celui plus tard
et ça fait vraiment c'est l'habit montre
qu'un pour moi bon il y avait aussi à
caméra explore les blancs y avait ce oui
aussi le théâtre de la jeunesse était
très bien en télésanté nab génial ça
c'était vraiment super bien et je
regardais tous et je regardais aussi
même des films qui étaient interdits et
notamment une émission sur jouera la
dernière revue des folies bergère est
donc là j'avais vu toutes ces femmes en
plus mais avec des bas résilles chever
dessinée ça le lendemain à l'école
bon et puis ils savaient pas tellement
plus quoi lassitude crise alors du coup
je vais faire tout le tour pour montrer
le dessin que j'avais fait mais moi
j'étais fier bon alors on te souhaite
beaucoup de succès avec ce bouquin plus
qu'avec mon disque mais méritée 1 à
succès comme ça j'ai quand même vendu 42
c'est vrai oui et j'ai été 52e presque
est pratiquement 65 ans voilà vraiment
été une semaine noire et lycées jean et
dira toute ma vie d'acheter alors dans
ton roman photo à la fin on voit tout
les amis rita mitsouko il a tort mais on
voit frédéric leur cabine plan du
travail avec toi et c'est yvette horner
la relooker complètement celui-là tu l'a
complètement revampé faut bien le dire
maintenant c'est madonna alors là
changement de changement de taille bah
oui oui le premier point commun c'est
d'abord que je suis un fan aussi bien
d'yvette horner que de madonna c'est
elle qui a appelé ses abris celui et
puis après il m'a donné le numéro pour
que je les rejoigne filet alors je
dirais c'est comment alors on va c'est
que j'étais au bord de l'apoplexie
finalement quand je vais savoir plus
c'est génial parce qu'à taiwan to speak
c'est aussi sous ip rigolote c'est quand
même vraiment bien alors après tu es
allé la voir à new york
voilà et puis ça c'est là qu'elle a un
frère avait quelques est un peu à
madonna ce qu'orlando était à dalida
c'est un défi la protège un peu il la
protège il est là il lui donne quelques
avis comme ces quelques touches mais
elle fait ce qu'elle veut enfin je veux
dire quand même c'est assez étonnant
parce que c'est elle allait absolument
pas diriger c'est elle qui décide dit ça
va ça va pas je veux ça c'était qui est
produit par exemple son prochain tour et
bombe à son frère il est là pour lui
donner quelques par exemple un moment
j'avais proposé mois parmi tous les
contenus je vais proposer comme une pré
vierge madone et tout je pensais un
moment qu'elle pourrait à l'issue d'une
douche et puis enfin que sa nudité se
révèle comme ça par le vêtement
transparent ça lui plaisait beaucoup
mais le frère lui l'était oui avec avec
la religion avec la veille quelques
petits problèmes
alors comme sandrine de pepsi ou de coca
oui voilà mais paraît-il à nouveau
non non pas du tout pièce qu'elle
discutait pognon c'est elle c'est elle
qui est assez incroyable c'est une vraie
business woman quoi elle est dure en
affaire allait malines la qualité avis
quand même et je dis une chose quand je
les fais je me suis dit tant pis si je
gagne rien là dessus ça me plaît et tous
bords ya des tas de choses que j'aurais
pu gagner vraiment mal et à revoir jean
paul oui oui je crois bien après les
venues en france te voir et elle est
venue à noël juste aux fêtes de fin
d'année et a passé le réveillon avec
elle voilà et warren beatty étaient pas
là il n'était pas là et la blanche oui
quand même
et enfin aller faire les essayages elle
avait perdu 6 kilos ben voila si cela se
faisait tout l'entraînement et tout ce
qu'il ya de génial quand même c est
incroyable c'est qu'elle s'entraîne tous
les jours
bon ça c'était la préparation aussi de
son choix je crois que dans sa vie de
tous les jours elle est hyper tu vois
genre health food large et ariel et
macrobiotique même de l'eau sur un
martini de temps en temps et yantaï
écoute j'ai pas les mesures en tête dont
je peux te dire qu'elle a une petite
taille qu'elle est merveilleusement pour
qui c'est quoi un 36 versio n'aimait pas
grande 1 m 65 65 avec des belles c'est
pour lui une belle poitrine dans les
parfaitement à c'est un petit bijou à
les superbes lorraine vient à paris là
au mois de juillet un match ira voir
tous les concerts je quitterai mais est
il était pas jean paul gaultier mais je
sais pas en fin de compte
j'ai pas non j'ai pas vraiment de héros
comme savoir enfin si les jours
heitz ouest